[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette
émission d' espace autochtones en direct
que nous avons décalé de deux jours en
fait une émission fort intéressante qui
va porter sur cette loi qui est entrée
en vigueur le 1er janvier la loi c'est
92 alors il ya beaucoup de monde ici à
montréal peu de monde en studio mais
isabelle picard est hélas toujours aussi
importante bonjour isabelle je remercie
et puis nous allons nous rendre à wendat
quai où se trouvent nos trois autres
invités d'abord alors allons-y avec
monsieur en premier on va faire
l'inversé monsieur richard gray richard
qui est gestionnaire des services
sociaux à la commission de la santé et
des services sociaux des premières
nations du québec et du labrador bonjour
monsieur gré monsieur gré vous
m'entendez bien oui alors à côté de vous
monsieur gré marjolaine si oui qui est
la directrice générale du c3s pnq elle
donjon madame si oui et puis à côté
jacinthe ledoux jacinthe et avocate pour
le bureau au caté avocat c'est un bureau
qui se trouve à toronto et qui
représente en tout cas dans le cas de
jacinthe les communautés autochtones
bonjour jacinthe bonjour à marie bonjour
isabelle alors nous vous entendons bien
il ya un léger délai donc mais tout va
bien vous êtes là toutes les trois tous
les trois merci d'ailleurs on va parler
de la loi donc ses 92
une loi qui a été adoptée en juin
dernier dont juin 2019 qui est entrée en
vigueur depuis le 1er janvier une loi
qui concerne les enfants les jeunes les
familles des premières nations des
inuits et des métis
alors ça englobe beaucoup de monde et
évidemment c'est une loi qui s'applique
à l'ensemble du canada c'est important
de le préciser parce que ces dernières
semaines on a beaucoup entendu parler du
québec par rapport à la loi c'est 92
mais pas du reste du canada et il ya une
raison à ça c'est que la loi a été
contestée par le gouvernement du québec
donc nous allons en parler au cours des
prochaines minutes
mais d'abord ce serait intéressant avec
notre panel
d'expliquer ce qu'est la loi c92 je
pense qu'on devrait commencer avec
marjolaine si oui parce que marjolaine
vous travaillé sur ce dossier j'imagine
là depuis depuis plusieurs mois sans
doute alors ce serait intéressant tout
de suite avec vous de parler des
principes de cette loi mais en fait
c'est sûr que c'est un travail collectif
qui a été fait par l'ensemble des
premières nations métier nous est à
travers le pays
par contre quand on regarde la loi c'est
quand même quelque chose qui veut c'est
une loi qui est venu affirmer le droit
et l'autodétermination des premières
nations ce qui était demandé depuis des
années d'avoir cette affirmation mais en
même temps ces principes qui ont été
adoptés ces les principes sur lesquels
tout le monde s'est entendu donc les
grands principes comme pour assurer
justement tout le côté culturel le côté
aussi de là avec qui famille de
l'appartenance aussi à la communauté
donc de reprendre en fait inchangé en
main notre façon de pouvoir gérer nos
services mais aussi accompagner nos
familles à l'intérieur d'une noix qui
nous ressemblait davantage que de par
des lois qui nous ont été posées
oui alors tout ça semble logique mais
tout cela n'est pas simple
d'ailleurs je le précise tout de suite
j'ai contacté le cabinet de la ministre
responsable des affaires autochtones à
québec
donc la ministre s'il vit d'amour est
lancée elle est absente elle sera de
retour le 24 janvier
donc j'aurais aimé que quelqu'un de son
bureau soit ici pour pour parler de la
loi bon pour parler aussi la
contestation mais je dois le dire là
tout le monde a décliné l'invitation
ce qui est un peu dommage mais de toute
façon on va quand même expliquer les
tenants et les aboutissants de cette loi
est d'ailleurs ce qui est important de
préciser c'est que la loi s applique en
ce moment partout depuis le 1er janvier
et ce même au québec et ce malgré la
contestation du québec
comment ça se fait comment ça se fait
que c'est possible de toutes façons de
de l'appliquer immédiatement peut-être
que jacinthe
nous répondre oui absolument alors
effectivement à marie vous avez raison
la loi s'applique en ce moment partout
au canada malgré la contestation
constitutionnelle que le québec
s'apprête à déposer
il faut comprendre qu'on ne peut pas
encore vu les documents que le québec va
déposer sa devrait se produire vers la
mi janvier ou le début février
et c'est vraiment quand on aura accès à
ces procédures qu'on pourra déterminer
jusqu'à quel point la loi c'est 92
continue de s'appliquer ou pas la
question fondamentale qui se pose c'est
de savoir si la procédure qui va être
déposée par le québec est accompagné
d'une injonction ou non d'une demande
d'injonction non s'il ya une demande
d'injonction c'est possible donc que la
loi c'est 92 soit potentiellement
interrompu que son application soit donc
suspendue jusqu'à ce qu'un jugement soit
rendu un jugement donc potentiellement
par la cour suprême
mais s'il n'y a pas de demande
d'injonction et jusqu'à maintenant dans
les décrets qui ont été adoptées par le
gouvernement du québec on ne voit pas
d'intention de déposer une demande
d'injonction donc la loi c'est 92 est en
application et devrait s'il n'y a pas de
demande des gens qui ont continué de
s'appliquer jusqu'à ce qu'un jugement de
la cour suprême ce qui peut prendre
plusieurs réserves a dit oui alors
évidemment le gouvernement n'est pas là
pour nous expliquer pourquoi il conteste
la loi mais je pense que tous vous le
savez un peu qui peut s'exprimer à ce
sujet là pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
contesté la loi qui a envie de répondre
un projet d'accord oui c'est moi emery
je peux partager mes pensées mais je
suis pas un avocat non plus je suis un
gestionnaire de sauver sociaux et j'ai
travaillé des années
avec macky min tit de l'estivage sur le
dos il peut thaksin de la jeunesse vit
une entente de délégation avec le
gouvernement du québec garde avec la
nouvelle on attendu depuis quelques mois
québec pour quelle raison ne sais pas
mais il commence contesté beaucoup de
loi déposé par le gouvernement ferait
mais avec les apologies en français ses
excuses dans l'assemblée nationale
octobre dernier on était très surprise
que par ses actions avec cette
compétition via la france de la cour
d'appel du québec a date aussi avec eux
la façon comment la commission laurent
et est entré de fait le grand saut
chronologique consultation publique du
québec comment améliorer la loi
protection de la jeunesse
et avec ces mots que la loi protection
de la jeunesse est brisé c'est une
grande surprise pour le prix munitions
que le québec a choisi de décider
d'aller dans cette chemin parce que le
ses lois ses 92 c'est vraiment une
occasion on n'a pas tout dit il pour
être le premier mission de travailler en
collaboration et coopération plus
approfondie avec québec et le
gouvernement fédéral aussi d'améliorer
notre l'avenir deux premiers pour nos
enfants prémunition oui oui c'est ça la
commission l'orangerie de préciser c'est
donc une commission qui se penche sur la
protection de la jeunesse de tous les
enfants québec l'a pas seulement les
enfants autochtones mais tous les
enfants au québec isabelle ça vous a
fait beaucoup réagir évidemment la
contestation du québec
oui oui effectivement ben on se souvient
qu'au 30 septembre dernier donc en 2019
le lion même pas six mois le la
commission vient déposer son rapport à
l'assemblée nationale
oui et ce faut pas oublier que cette
commission là elle avait été nommée
mandaté par le gouvernement du québec
oui et la première chose que le juge
vient au dit c'est que les autochtones
sont victimes de discrimination
systémique dans les services publics du
québec
or qu'est-ce que c'est une
discrimination systémique
ben en fait c'est le système qui va
faire en sorte qu'un individu ou d'un
groupe d'individus vont être brimés dans
ces îles mais mis à part être
discriminés vont être traités
différemment en fait et ça ça peut-être
au niveau historique politique au niveau
administratif donc ça peut être à plein
de niveaux et monsieur gréau tout à fait
raison je les jolies écrit dans
plusieurs chroniques
la contestation de la loi ces 92 c'est
un exemple flagrant de cette
discrimination systémique le dont il est
question
parce que en fait c'est quoi c'est
l'histoire d'une guerre ou une bataille
incessante en incessantes entre le
gouvernement du québec et le
gouvernement du canada
oui concernant des chicanes
constitutionnelles finalement elop qui
vont en faire les frais
mais ce sont les premières nations et
les inuits ont donc j'ai de la
difficulté à comprendre comment cette
contestation judiciaire la peut prendre
place dans un tel une telle époque où on
a eu le rapport de la commission vient
on a eu les excuses de la part du chef
du gouvernement monsieur legault il
vraiment c'est ça a été vraiment une
surprise
et on dit bon bain l'ailé en bon
français en bon québécois
les bottines ne suivent pas les babines
parce que quelque part il ya une excuse
mais non coté on s'en va et on met un
peu un bâton dans la wii jacinthe le
doubs pour vous pour les avocats ça va
vous donner énormément de travail
j'imagine au cours des des prochains
mois et des prochaines années cette
contestation
oui bon je pense à marie qu'on aurait
préféré que ce soit plus flux et de
danse ne cherche pas ne peut faire mal à
obtenir
du travail dans un contexte comme
celui-là on aurait préféré travailler a
affirmé à continuer à affirmer
l'autonomie gouvernementale des
premières nations dans le cadre de la
loi de 92 à revitaliser les systèmes
autochtone de protection de l'enfance et
de la jeunesse je pense que ce type de
travail leur aurait été beaucoup plus
intéressant que de se retrouver encore
dans ce qu'isabelle très bien qualifiés
tant pis terni le sempiternel débat
constitutionnel entre le québec et le
fédéral et la raison disons juridique
pour laquelle le québec dépose cette
contestation constitutionnelle c'est que
bon on fait traditionnellement au niveau
politique le québec conteste les lois
fédérales qui ont prépondérance mais
dans ce cas ci le québec en fait les
provinces toutes les provinces
canadiennes ont une compétence exclusive
en matière de de services à la famille
de protection de la jeunesse et le
fédéral a une compétence exclusive pour
ce qui concerne les autochtones au
canada
mais là ce qui se passe c'est que on
parle de système de protection de la
jeunesse autochtone alors on se retrouve
un peu entre deux chaises et où est cet
espace là en fait tu es dans l'article
35 de la loi constitutionnelle de 1982
et cet article 35 que reconnaît et
affirment les droits ancestraux et issus
traiter de toutes les premières nations
de tout les autochtones au canada et
c'est là dessus sur cet article 35 qui
est le pilier de l'autonomie
gouvernementale autochtone que repose la
loi c'est 92 et ses loques hier le
québec qui est angle aveugle en
défendant sa propre autonomie en matière
de protection de la jeunesse et on parle
si le québec non c'est communication
publique parle de compétence exclusive
oublie donc qu'il ya cet article 35 de
la loi constitutionnelle de 1982 qui
donc qui parle d'autonomie
gouvernementale des premières nations
alors une précision lundi prochain
les chefs autochtones doivent se réunir
le chef ghislain picard la pnq elle mais
aussi les différents chefs donc pour
voir ça va être quoi la stratégie pour
la suite parce qu'il y aura une
rencontre avec la ministre d'amour qui
sera de retour le 27
donc une rencontre à ce sujet là entre
autres le 27 et donc une rencontre entre
les chefs le vin là on va laisser les
disputes de côté et on va vraiment
plongés dans la loi ces 92 les articles
de cette loi il y en a plusieurs il y en
a certains qui sont particulièrement
importants jacinthe oui il y eu des
avancées extrêmement intéressante
extrêmement importante dans la loi ces
notamment il y a pour revenir à
l'article 35
il y a l'affirmation du droit inhérent
des peuples autochtones à l'autonomie
gouvernementale et l'affirmation que
dans ce droit à l'autonomie gouvernante
gouvernementale se trouve la compétence
des premières nations a exercé les leur
juridiction en matière de protection de
la jeunesse et des services aux familles
c'est extrêmement important c'est une
grande avancée
c'était aussi un pas dans la bonne
direction pour la mise en oeuvre de la
déclaration des nations unies pour les
droits des peuples autochtones coquen le
canada a adhéré et il y à d'autres
articles extrêmement importantes comme
par exemple une réaffirmation du
principe de la continuité culturelle
pour les enfants autochtones
on sait que sous la loi sur la
protection de la jeunesse québécoise
un des problèmes que la commission vient
soulever et que beaucoup d'intervenants
ont soulevé c'est les délais de
placement maximo c'est à dire que après
des délais qui peuvent aller jusqu'à
deux ans où un enfant est placé dans une
famille d'accueil
même une famille d'accueil non
autochtone l'enfant veut ensuite être
placé de manière permanente jusqu'à
l'atteinte de sa majorité
est ce cette clause la dans la loi sur
la protection de la jeunesse ont généré
beaucoup de dépossession culturel on
désunis les familles et ça s'est inscrit
en continuité de d'autant plus
traumatisant c7 ces gens de closer
dans le contexte où il ya eu les écoles
résidentielles d'abord qui ont été des
attaques très ciblées sur les familles
autochtones ou puis ensuite la rafle des
années 60 qui ont été encore une
dépossession culturel puis une
déstructuration des familles par l'état
canadien
alors la lp de la loi sur la protection
de la jeunesse
c'est ce genre de clause qui prévoit
déplacement permanent cela s'inscrit
aussi dans une continuité historique qui
est très troublante en fait c'est comme
une continuité du colonialisme des fois
on entend des discours publics que c'est
dans le passé mais non quand on a des
choses comme celles là on voit bien que
c'est présent et la loi c'est 92 en
réaffirmant l'importance du principe de
continuité culturelle pour les enfants
autochtones en réaffirmant l'importance
d'interpréter la notion de l'intérêt de
l'enfant
en axant donc sur la continuité
culturelle sur la réunification des
familles viennent y faire un pas très
important dans une version qui était
demandée depuis longtemps par les
premières nations et par les peuples
autochtones
oui je ne vois pas réagir à côté
marjolaine et richard marjolaine ce que
vous voulez ajouter quelque chose à ce
que à ce que dit jacinthe mais peut-être
d autres éléments qui sont importants on
parle d'égalité réelle donc si vous
regardez avec tout le tribunal canadien
des droits de la personne avec la cause
au niveau du principe de jardin en
incluant principe de jardin eh bien on
vient réaffirmer de cette façon là parce
que ce qu'on ce qu'on veut atteindre
justement c'est cette égalité là de
pouvoir mettre des systèmes en place qui
vont davantage ressembler ou est ce
qu'on va pouvoir décider aussi des
façons de faire c'est ce que je pense
que tout le monde les communautés sont
toutes à l'affût de savoir dans une
certaine façon on au des principes de
base à respecter mais en même temps ce
qu'on veut donner c'est davantage une
une appartenance à laquelle ou est ce
que la communauté complète va être
impliqué dans la dent dans tout le
processus au niveau d'établir nos
propres systèmes en protection de la
jeunesse ou un service web conserver de
protection peut-être aussi à l'intérieur
de sousse qui est important c'est que
quand tout à l'heure on parlait des
placements a causé par steam en
permanence ou même critique ce résultat
aussi par des adoptions et bien à
l'intérieur de son no quand même eu
certaines avancées avec la loi
provinciale au niveau de la
reconnaissance des effets de l'adoption
coutumière par contre la loi fédérale où
la loi que les communautés dont elles
décideront de se doter pourront
davantage aller plus loin dans ses
aspects le haut niveau aussi de la
protection des enfants mais aussi avec
l'adoption mais les familles et
peut-être rappeler quand même des
statistiques importantes pour comprendre
l'ampleur de la situation actuelle au
canada les enfants autochtones
représentent 7 points 7 % de la
population des enfants
oui ou alors qu ils sont cinquante deux
pour cent du total les enfants place et
donc par les différents systèmes de
protection de la jeunesse dans les
différentes provinces et territoires
donc c'est quand même important au
québec c'est 15 points 14 15 points 4 %
d'enfants autochtones qui sont placés
dans le système alors qu'ils
représentent environ 2% de la population
si je me trompe pas mais il ya même des
provinces dans les prairies le manitoba
je pense que ces 87 % des enfants qui
sont placés qui sont d'origine
autochtone ou métis en alberta c'est à
peu près la même chose en saskatchewan
je veux ça pas de bon sens et ces
enfants là le plus important ces
chiffres choquants mais oui absolument
ils sont souvent placés à l'extérieur
des communautés parce qu'on n'a pas les
capacités d'accueil on au pôle de
financement qu'il faut on ne peut pas
donc cette loi love certainement
permettre un meilleur avenir pour ces
enfants ne me reviennent constamment
être le rôle du du c3s pnq elle parce
que j'imagine que vous allez aider les
communautés entre autres dans la
rédaction des lois que ces gens là vont
vouloir implanter déjà le rôle que vous
avez eu à jouer jusqu'à présent jusqu'à
l'adoption de là
loi c92 c'était quoi au sein de la du
c3s pnq elle commencé puis passé richard
houis complété vous ajoutez des
compliments mais l'euro de la commission
en fait son nid une organisation des
premières nations qui est qui qui est
mise sur pied par les chefs des
communautés
donc notre rôle a toujours été de 2,1 au
niveau de la défense des intérêts au
niveau de l'accompagnement au niveau
aussi d'un rôle conseil est bizarre
c'est toujours sur une base bien sûr
dépendamment du besoin aussi de ce que
la communauté s'attend donc au niveau
plus particulièrement au niveau des
services sociaux bien c'est qu'on
accompagne on travaille beaucoup aussi
au niveau des services de prévention de
propres services préventifs de première
ligne
peut-être si on retourne un peu en
arrière jusqu'en 2010 les communautés à
travers le pays ne n'avais aucun
financement pour mettre des services de
prévention première ligne au sein des
communautés donc c'est un élément très
important parce que lorsque la loi au
québec a changé en 2007
eh bien on partait avec un pot un peu en
arrière donc on n'était pas une façon
équitable en faire en termes de
financement termes de services en termes
de soutien
donc lorsque la loi lorsque on parlait
tout à l'heure
déplacement permanent avec les enfants
et bien quand on la loi venait prescrire
des délais ou quoi que ce soit bien les
familles ou les communautés n'était pas
au dossier ou avec tout ce qu'il leur
fallait pour pouvoir mettre de l'avant
ses choses donc maintenant depuis 2010
on a ces services préventifs donc c'est
au niveau de notre organisation qu'on a
accompagné les communautés qu'ils
souhaitaient à pouvoir mettre sur pied
aussi tout un aspect de réseautage un
aspect de rassemblement des intervenants
ou est ce qu ils peuvent aussi se
c'est changer les meilleures pratiques
s'échangeait aussi leur façon de faire
de voir comment elles cheminent elles
s'entraident aussi entre les communautés
donc c'est quand même tout un réseau de
kimi en grand pour pouvoir travailler
donc c'est une concertation alors vous
richard c'est moi je voulais ajouter
oui moi je voulais acheter quelque chose
complémentaires qui étaient partagés
tout à la jacinthe au niveau de la loi
qui est échangé pour qu'ils introduisent
de nouveaux concepts placement permanent
au placement de vie c'était en 2007
cette femme une loi de changement plutôt
qu'une de la jeunesse était interdit
dans l'assemblée nationale d'antan on a
ce qu'on s'appelle la loi 125 mais le
chose on est très contentes dans la loi
l'opportunité dans la loi ces 92 c'est
la prémunition maintenant aller nouveau
stand national qui oblige et toutes les
provinces de respecter au poteau de paix
du canada mais le fait que si le prix
munitions vont développer leur propre
loi qui est permis dans section vendent
dans la loi ces 92
il ya deux possibilités que quand québec
change la loi dans l'avenir pour le
besoin de population québec en général
normalement quand il fait ses
changements de lois il ne pas tenir
compte des réalités de premières nations
tout à fait et le premier natio par
conséquence doivent vécu ces changements
riel dans la loi énormément
le changement québec fait c'est pour le
bruit à l'été la population québec en
jaune vert et ne pas tenir compte
spécifiquement le reality deux premiers
nations unies mais je pense avec son
doigt ses 92 et le nouveau principe
national
ce sera vraiment donner un avis toute la
province de roupies au pde canada 2
garder le respect pour la prémunition et
les aspects notre histoire on a vécu
vis-à-vis le trauma historique mais
aussi le taux de placement on a
mentionné tout allait pas par isabelle
mais québec
oui on n'a pas de même circonstance
comme d'autres provinces dans l'ouest de
pays canada mais on lui avait dit la
prémunition maintenant voulait prise en
charge l'avenir avec la possibilité qui
existe dans ces 92 et si québec vont
agir encore avec le changement garde de
consultation commission laurent est en
train de faire actuellement
et oui on va faire on va participer dans
la consultation mais gardent quand
est-ce qu'ils aient québec vont vraiment
ce soir avec le premier chiot devrait
m'a parlé avec nous sur nos entre et
comment quelle est l'opportunité
occasion pour pourvoir cette discussion
ouvert franche avec québec tu regardes
ça c'est nos besoins on vraiment créer
une loi pour nous mais comment ce que
vous pouvez aider nous dans 700 cela au
lieu de perdre nos temps des chicken
d'encours et encore le premier sont pris
dans le chicken fermés au 10è je trouve
ça très dommage oui
expliquez nous comment vous allez
appliquer la loi bon on laisse le québec
de côté là vous vous mettez au travail
j'imagine que les communautés les
différentes nations vont se tourner vers
vous pour que vous les aidiez à
appliquer maintenant les la loi c'est 92
dans leur communauté que chacun puisse
créer sa propre juridiction
en fait ce qui est important c'est que
les gens s'approprient ce que ça veut
dire la loi
donc est ce qu'on a déjà commencé à
faire c'est de mobiliser
petit peu en faisant des
visioconférences en faisant des
matériels pour mieux faire comprendre
qu'est ce que ça veut dire parce qu'on à
différentes personnes qu' il faut
atteindre donc le leadership c'en est un
par contre il ya aussi les intervenants
ceux qui appliquent ou qui doivent faire
les services de protection de prévention
à chaque jour dans leur communauté
il ya aussi les familles qui doivent
être au courant aussi les avec les
enfants donc on a dit roy ou c'est en
tant que personne donc il faut qu'on
soit à l'affût de ces choses donc
présentement
compte tenu de ce qui s'est passé avec
le québec avait beaucoup de confusion à
savoir ce que les gens disent eh ben ça
s'applique ça s'applique pas qu'est ce
qui s'applique aujourd'hui donc tout ça
il faut continuer de faire justement
beaucoup de sensibilisation pour bien
faire comprendre c'est sûr que c'est un
dossier complexe
éventuellement si on avait je sais pas
moi
20 communautés qui décide de faire leurs
propres lois
et bien c'est sûr que bon ça à sa
demande une analyse faut aussi bien
préparer le québec au niveau de son
réseau parce qu'eux aussi ont encore une
responsabilité au niveau de
l'application de leurs propres lois
mais en même temps en ce qu'on sait
c'est que lorsque le
le geste a été posé par le québec
eh bien on a posé la question à savoir
quel était le clan de mise en oeuvre de
la loi au niveau des principes par le
québec est la réponse qu'on a vu c'est
on n'a pas vraiment de plan et malgré
même si on va voir jugement à entendre
un niveau de la cour supérieure il faut
que quand même tous les jours ça va
s'appliquer depuis le 1er janvier
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
sensibiliser davantage au niveau que ce
soit le système judiciaire que ce soit
au niveau du réseau avec juste justement
au niveau de la protection de la
jeunesse donc avec les réseaux décidé
sus du québec
donc il ya énormément de travail à faire
présentement je suis aussi que haut
niveau quand on regarde on a des
discussions avec la commission au niveau
d'acidité des juifs pour la protection
de la jeunesse pour voir eux
quel est leur rôle à travers tout ça
donc c'est sûr pour eux la loi
s'applique donc la loi fédérale la loi
provinciale et jusqu'à prochaine
indépendamment de commencent à réagir a
aussi au niveau du positionnement mais
encore une fois c'est beaucoup de
sensibilisation présentement
par contre on sait que quand même des
communautés qui ont levé la main qui ont
sont intéressés et qu'elles sont
probablement prête à faire un premier
pas pour dire bien nous on a notre
intention donc elles doivent signifier
leur intention au gouvernement fédéral
au gouvernement provincial pour dire
qu'elles veulent développer l'emploi
donc dans ce sens l'homme y est on
accompagne avec ce conte ce qu'ont pu
l'accompagner donc de faire bien
comprendre les différents types de
régime au niveau de la loi les
différents éléments qu'est ce que ça
veut dire et c'est sûr et certain que on
parle ici d'un tout un volet légal ou
est ce que la communauté aussi doit
à voir le site est nécessaire à ce
niveau là ah oui justement j'allais vous
poser la question s'il y avait des
communautés déjà qu'ils s'étaient
montrés intéressés à travailler tout de
suite sur une loi jacinthe est ce que
vous avez eu l'occasion de parler avec
certaines communautés qui ont envie de
déjà de se lancer
oui je peux vous dire que je confirme
l'information que marjolaine a mis de
l'avant il ya certaines communautés qui
souhaite effectivement se lancer dans
des négociations là je pense que ça vaut
la peine de prendre un peu de recul un
peu puis pour ceux qui n'ont jamais lu
la loi c'est 92 touristes qui n'ont
jamais lu non plus d'articles qui résume
la loi en gros ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que depuis le 1er janvier les lois
la loi provinciale et pour la première
fois dans toute l'histoire du canada une
loi fédérale ou steam et une en
s'appliquant protection de la jeunesse
au québec
alors avant le 1er janvier 2020 c'était
uniquement la loi sur la protection de
la jeunesse qui s'appliquait et
maintenant lieu de loi est la loi
fédérale
elle est beaucoup plus courte elle
prévoit ce qu'ils appellent des normes
minimales qui vont s'appliquer à tous
les enfants autochtones au canada en
plus de la loi sur la protection de la
jeunesse provincial et ruptures de le
mentionner c'est extrêmement important
la loi c'est 92 permet aux premières
nations au peuple autochtone de négocier
ce qu'ils appellent des accords de
coordination avec le gouvernement
québécois et avec le gouvernement
canadien pour appliquer et développer
leurs propres lois
alors leur propre façon de prendre soin
des enfants docteurs chaque communauté
maintenant à cette opportunité cette
possibilité de négocier de développer
leurs propres régimes de protection de
l'enfance et de la jeunesse
et ça c'est nouveau c'est nouveau et
c'est important parce que une fois que
je suis d'accord de coordination là sont
mises en oeuvre sont adoptés ils ont
préséance lits vont avoir priorité sur
les lois provinciales et sur la loi sur
la protection de la jeunesse c'est pour
ça que quand arthur lui parlais tantôt 2
la modification qui a eu lieu concernant
les placements permanent des
modifications comme celle là dans le
futur quand il ya encore de coordination
en place pourront pas affecter la
juridiction autochtone qui va être qui
va avoir prépondérant vous y avoir
priorité franchement ce qu'ils appellent
à ce sujet là vous avez une question
ben oui en fait j'ai beaucoup lu parce
qu'on a entendu plusieurs choses sur
cette loi lapin angora la contestation
au tce terol rôle du fédéral provincial
donc si j'ai bien compris en code d'un
contact compatibilité la loi fédérale va
supplanter la loi provincial de la
protection de la jeunesse le vont comme
juillet mais les lois autochtone vont
supplanter la loi fédérale quand ils
vont être adoptées j'ai une question en
fait parce que au-delà de tout ça
évidemment bien sûr toutes les lois
autochtone doivent s'inscrire à
l'intérieur de la charte canadienne des
droits et libertés
bon les droits de la personne et j'étais
rôle comprend bien et au delà de tout ça
il ya l'intérêt de l'enfant qui va
primer or on sait que le meilleur
intérêt de l'enfant est sujet à
interprétation en lien avec sa culture
avec sa communauté avec ses valeurs et
généreux on voit déjà sur le terrain et
on l'a vu par le passé le la loi de la
protection de la jeunesse donc le
gouvernement provincial qui arrivait
avec les dpj et qui disait bambins
t-elle enfin nous on estime qu' il est
mal encadrée et à l'intérieur de la
communauté diab et non c'est une manière
traditionnelle on fait les choses de
cette façon là donc c'est des choses qui
peuvent arriver
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand il ya un
espèce de problèmes de compatibilité ou
de d'interprétation comme si on veut
régler le problème
c'est tellement une bonne question
isabelle bon alors il n'y a pas de
réponse noire ou blanche c'est une
question complexe qui la réponse est
complexe aussi mais ce que je peux dire
c'est que la loi c'est 92 ajoute des
outils supplémentaires pour les peuples
autochtones orieux ses arrières du port
et de contre on va faire le pauvre en
premier
alors la bonne nouvelle c'est que
l'article 9 de la loi ces 92 vient
définir de manière beaucoup plus
détaillé ce qui doit être prise en
considération pour déterminer ce qui
dans le meilleur intérêt de l'enfant
alors dans les principes de l'arctique 9
pour déterminer l'intérêt de l'enfant il
ya vraiment une emphase encore le sur la
prise la continuité culturelle le
contexte autochtone alors l'emphase est
vraiment mis là dessus le problème c'est
que qui va interpréter le meilleur
intérêt de l'enfant dans les contextes
judiciariser c'est qui alors ça va le
dpj
les travailleurs sociaux les juges de la
cour du québec
alors ça c'est un problème et
j'ajouterai que avec ce problème là
ailleurs l'article 23 de la loi ces 92
qui permet au juge de passer outre les
lois docteur si c'est jugé dans le
meilleur intérêt de l'enfant alors c'est
pas voilà c'est mi figue mi raisin
effectivement est ce que j'ai pensé
mairie oui à l'isi il ya quelque chose
je voulais ajouter je pense c'est pour
ça c'est très important
la prémunition commence à voir des
discussions au niveau de tripartite avec
le gouvernement fédéral et le
gouvernement provincial et les premiers
mission de discuter dans le cas de
conflit de lois juridictionnelle quel
est le moyen de proposer la solution et
je pense ça c'est un élément très
important de 2,2 vraiment clarifier dans
la famille entend de coordination aussi
est ce qu'il pourrait y avoir est ce que
les provinces pourrait s'immiscer dans
le travail des communautés pour dire ah
mais vous devriez vous arrimé à ce qu'on
fait déjà est ce que ça pourrait se
produire ça que une province où l'autre
la veille
essayez de l'idée le travail des
différentes communautés parce que en
fait les communautés yahia mettons
parlons du québec
il ya 54 communauté au québec quand on
compte également le nunavik donc légende
dans le nord et chacun pourrait avoir
une loi différente
est-ce que les gens les différentes
nations vont se mettre ensemble pour
travailler ou est ce que chacun va
travailler de son côté est ce que si
chacun travaille de son côté il peut pas
y avoir une influence du gouvernement
qui va leur dire hein vous devriez le
faire de telle ou telle manière à ce que
c'est un danger que je répondrai à ce
niveau là c'est qu'on voit des jeunes
certaine influence comme vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure il ya quand même une
particularité au québec
lorsqu'on parle des communautés qui ont
signé une convention
donc la nation crie la 908 naskapis et
pour l'ensemble des autres communautés
est ce qu'on voit présentement c'est sûr
et certain que pour les communautés
cries nouettes en escales pied on a le
système bon avec la protection de la
jeunesse est aussi un article dans la
loi de la protection de la jeunesse au
québec qui est l'article 37 5 qui permet
des communautés des premières nations
est doux et de ceux de se doter d'un
régime particulier en matière de
protection de la jeunesse et you on a un
exemple au québec avec la nation
atikamekw mais aussi ce qu'on a su
dernièrement c'est que la nation avec la
nation crie mais aussi chez les inuit on
a de la part du québec fait des avancées
en disant bon il ya quand même la loi
c'est 92 qui peut aussi s'appliquer à
eux donc ils ont aussi cette option là
mais en même temps lundi bien que vous
êtes déjà avec le cas de la protection
de la jeunesse des lois du québec bien
pourquoi ne pas conclure à d'un peu plus
loin dans votre démarche et conclure une
entente de par article 37 5 points
niveau de la loi et avec eux on voit des
gens quand même des tendances aux ibères
il pourrait avoir différents régimes au
québec donc on a des communautés qui
pourraient opter pour avoir leurs
propres lois donc à travers la loi avec
ses 92
on pourrait aussi avoir les communautés
qui ont le statut quo qui demeure avec
avec la loi de la protection de la
jeunesse
on pourra voir à travers la loi avant de
conclure un régime particulier donc on
prend plus de responsabilité de ton
ennemi d'une certaine façon
donc ça c'est ça ça devient une une
décision au niveau des communautés
on pourrait avoir aussi un regroupement
des différentes communautés d'une même
nation qui décide de se doter aussi de
la loi avec ses principes donc un grande
diversité
puis on entend ainsi que dans d'autres
provinces au niveau des premières
nations il pourrait avoir une grande
majorité ou avoir des autorités qui se
mettrait sur pied pour un grand ensemble
de communautés même avec différentes
nations donc c'est très diversifié
beaucoup de diversité à l'intérieur de
pouvoir permettre mais en même temps
mais ça devient toujours à la base une
décision l'aude des gouvernements des
premières nations
oui est ce cui alesi je sonne je vous
vois lever la main je veux simplement
ajouter une petite précision votre
question aussi concernés l'implication
potentielle du québec puis l'influencé
que le québec pourrait avoir dans ces
négociations des accords de coordination
il faut savoir que d'après ses quatre
succès 92 qu'une première nation ou un
groupe de première nation ou de peuple
autochtone fait ses meilleurs efforts
pour conclure un accord de coordination
après un an que les gouvernements
canadiens ou provinciaux accepte ou pas
l'accord de coordination qui classe va
être en vigueur
évidemment ça peut poser des problèmes
au niveau du financement qui est
accessible mais ça fait en sorte que les
premières nations après un an de
meilleurs efforts pour conclure un
accord vont pouvoir avoir quand même une
loi qui tangue
oui ok est ce que richard voulait
ajouter quelque chose non alors une
formation supplémentaire avec qu'est-ce
que jacinthe a déjà partagé actuellement
dans le
la région de québec il ya de l'argent le
qui me tire dessus
vu l'engouement farewell sac
c'est peut-être ce symptôme canada
actuellement poule
le programme enfance famille et l'argent
est présentement disponible pour le
service protection de la jeunesse
la plupart de khemisti permission non
conventionnés sont déjà prises en charge
le service de protection de la jeunesse
vient en tête des délégations avec
québec actuel et ça veut dire il ya
l'argent déjà disponibles quand on nous
parle
un an temps de connexion vie de
développer une loi c'est 92
pour moi les choses qui manquent présent
qu'on manque présentement mais pas juste
ici dans région québec mais euros pour
couper du canada aussi c'est le fait
qu'on n'a aucune de l'argent disponible
via le gouvernement fédéral pour
développer nos propres lois nos propres
systèmes
ça c'est la chose dont on soit et
j'espère ça va être adressée dans notre
prochaine budgétaires faits réels mais
quand le crime et ils vont développer
leur propre loi la loi qui existe
présentement dans le programme enfance
famille promet nation va être transféré
personne dans ce sens logique dans le
dans la communauté ou nation qui vont
développer leur propre loi
ça veut dire ça va être oui peut-être ça
va être un agite de plus l'argent mais
l'aja déjà existent donc se destine we
had aux images la jsk excuse moi mais
peut-être y mentionner c'est que dès le
départ dit ça été un enjeu de qualité
soulevé au niveau de lorsqu'on élaborer
la loi
paroisse
quand même groupe technique depuis mis
en place mais aussi des chefs qui avait
un gros comité des chefs qui n'ait subi
su pouvoir accompagner au niveau
politique mais ça a été soulevé à
maintes reprises au niveau du
financement de pouvoir justement
s'assurer qu'elles ses provisions là au
niveau des budgets pour qu'on puisse
aller plus loin puis mettre en place
puis originaux structure à l'intérieur
de ça donc peut-être probablement ce qui
fait que ça l'amène sait où il ya des
communautés qui lève la main en disant
oui on veut s'affirmer on veut on veut
faire nos propres lois en même temps
mais il ya toujours la crainte en disant
bien on est des jeux sous-financé dents
dans la majorité de nos services et nos
programmes dans les communautés donc ça
devient on
c'est de toujours se reposer sur
qu'est-ce qu'on a présentement sans
avoir des investissements
supplémentaires pour pouvoir y chercher
une plus grande offre de services à
notre population
donc pour plusieurs ça peut être un
enjeu lorsqu'on connaît la difficulté
socio-économique présentement ça même
aussi à parler d'un élément qu'on
soulève pas souvent on parle de la loi
oui c'est une chose mais on ne peut pas
vraiment il ignorer tout fait qu' on
doit travailler son ensemble est
déterminant au niveau de quand on parle
de protection quand on parle au niveau
des communautés parce que quand on parle
de garder davantage nos enfants au sein
de la communauté ou quand on veut mettre
des moyens en place bien si on n'a pas
le logement qui est suffisant
l'intérieur de sociaux n'a pas
l'ensemble des services qui est encore
en mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait donc on est
toujours limité en quelque part et au
québec bien parce que je parlais du
québec
au québec on encore au dessus de 9000
unités de logements qui sont manquantes
au sein des communautés parce qu'une
seule population au niveau des dents
dans les logements
donc comment on résout tout ça donc ça
prend pas seulement des investissements
au niveau de mettre nos structures nos
systèmes en place mais on a aussi besoin
dans d'autres déterminants qui vont nous
aider à pouvoir contrer ce problématique
nokia va aller de l'avant puis avoir
minimalement des services qui vont se
comparer comparable à qu'est ce qu'on
trouve puis on veut faire plus on veut
pas seulement se comparer mais là c'est
une inquiétude aussi de savoir que la
loi est entrée en vigueur le 1er janvier
mais que pour l'instant on n'a jamais
parlé de financement il n'y a pas
d'argent concret là qui va arriver au
cours des prochaines semaines à ce qu'on
doit attendre le prochain budget fédéral
pour savoir à combien vous aurez droit
qui peut répondre à la question tout le
monde
oui mais mais mais dans le dans le
nouvel on attendu les premiers chefs
sortie pal
[Musique]
le premier mission de saskatchewan ils
ont demandé 360 millions chaque année
pour cinq ans ça veut dire ça va donner
1.8 milliard pour la prochaine cinq
heures mais le premier nation de québec
certainement on va participer dans la
discussion pour les aspects que j'étais
certainement est-ce que je sois fédéral
ne s'est pas encore prononcé
officiellement ce qu'on a entendu dans
les médias cette semaine
la partie fédérale ou du ministre des
finances s'était il faut attendre le
budget moment pour voir donc ça s'en
promettent on est vraiment dans le cc
c'est vraiment nébuleux présentement
mais je pense qu'il ya aussi des
positionnements aussi de politique mais
aussi il faut être capable de pouvoir
faire avancer les choses puis aussi de
faire bouger parce que puis en même
temps si je me dis bien de l'est québec
malheureusement pas sa course à côté
d'une très belle occasion de pouvoir
avoir amélioré sa relation d'être allé
un poids d'avant avec ça quand on
conteste pour une province
samson ses capacités au niveau de la
constitution bien en même temps de
gestes qu'ils posent et bien ça va mais
nous aussi c'est comme si on remet la
loi constitutionnelle des premières
nations donc c'est difficile aussi de
regarder ça d'une façon où est-ce qu'on
s'a nous cc c'est un petit peu une façon
de confronter mais en même temps de non
reconnaissance de nos de nos façons et
de nous de nos droits donc c'est très
douce et l'eau c'est j'imagine que c'est
une inquiétude particulière pour pouvoir
avancer quand on ne sait pas ce qui va
se passer au cours des prochains mois
des prochaines années alors qu'au
contraire c'est maintenant qu'on doit
agir et on le voit encore on parlait de
la pauvreté au canada chez les enfants
et on se rend compte que une fois de
plus et ce sont les enfants autochtones
qui sont le plus touchés et ça c'est ses
sorties encore ces jours ci donc au
niveau de la pauvreté au niveau de la
santé au niveau du placement des enfants
qui sont les enfants les plus touchés ce
sont encore et toujours les enfants
autochtones chose qu'on peut dire qu'on
est allé morizet normandie qu'est-ce
qu'on peut être sur la seule chose qu'on
est certain c'est qu'on aime nos enfants
puis qu'on veut on veut s'assurer qu'ils
aient tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour
pouvoir cheminer dans leur avenir et qui
de mieux que les familles et les
communautés pour pouvoir décider de sang
absolument
jacinthe j'aurais aimé vous entendre on
va revenir au financement en fait je
dirais plutôt au nom financement vous
même dans le travail que vous avez à
faire avec les communautés actuellement
est ce que c'est une entrave majeure le
financement fait le talon d'achille pas
seulement de la loi ces 92 mais je vais
rester le talon d'achille des services
de prévention de tous les services
d'accompagnement je pense que ce que
marshall un indice est extrêmement
important ça fait des années que les
premières nations se battre devant
non seulement au niveau de la
mobilisation politique au canada mais
aussi devant le tribunal canadien des
droits de la personne où il ya eu des
gains importants mais si ça continue
d'être une bataille pour que les
services de prévention qu'ils soient qui
sont offerts pour les enfants
autochtones qui sont ces réserves soient
de qualité suffisante pour atteindre
l'objectif de l'égalité réelle les quais
pas de discrimination alors ça c'est je
pense que c'est fondamental faut on le
répétera jamais assez le c'est le nerf
de la guerre entre autres puis sinon
pour revenir spécifiquement à ces 80 et
c'était de legrand talon d'achille alors
quels financements on était tous surpris
encore lu le dernier budget fédéral de
voir qu'ils avaient ri pour ses 92 ans à
sa cause est une question importante
quelles sont les intentions réelles du
gouvernement canadien dans la
négociation de ces accords de
coordination signe ni financement pour
supporter les démarches de négociations
avec les gouvernements fédéral et
provinciaux s'il n'y a ni financement
pour supporter les premières nations
dans la revitalisation de leur propre
système de protection de la jeunesse et
de l'enfance
et s'il n'ya ni financements annoncés
pour offrir une stabilité dans le
financement au service aux familles et
en protection de la jeunesse
c'était je pense il vous pouvez
confirmer
ou nuancer mais je pense que c'était une
grande déception chez beaucoup de
premières nations de voir qu'après tant
d'années de bataille politique et
juridique la loi c'est 92 ne ferait pas
une base juridique stable pour qui un
financement continu est stable et
permanent axée sur les besoins réels des
enfants dans les communautés alors à
partir de maintenant sachant ce que l'on
sait sa chance que l'on n'a pas dans les
poches pour travailler comment chacun de
vous au sein de vos organisme allait
fonctionner commençons avec et richard
puisque vous êtes de gestionnaires des
services sociaux pour le c3 spn qu elle
c'est quoi votre travail là des
prochains jours des prochains mois mais
présentement j'ai participé dans un quai
meeting national technique cela une
plantation et à 1992 avec le premier
nation ou groupe et du canada
certainement on va continuer notre
travail pour discuter avec le groupement
faire durer le soutien pour développer
un plan d'action concret pour les
premiers mission pour chaque région dans
notre région ici à québec on a aussi
développé qui me dit des experts pour
notre région pour donner une soutien
auprès munitions qui souhaitent de
commencer au début tu es le process de
développer un accord de coordination
aussi mais c'est on a invité la provence
et le gouvernement ferveur de participer
aussi dans cette famille
comité des experts et vous les avez
invité quelques elles ont été leurs
réponses mais on a eu la confirmation de
leur côté les mouvements farewell mais
on écrit une lettre direct au ministère
de santé services sociaux la remise
entente pour avoir la participation mais
on n'a pas obtenu une réponse à date
pour le confirmer leur participation
marjolaine de votre côté les prochaines
semaines est ce que les communautés les
diverses nations se tourne beaucoup vers
vous en ce moment à ce qu'il ya des
questions spécifiques dont ils veulent
entendre une réponse mais en fait ça
vient à différents niveaux
comme je disais tout à l'heure bon
certaines sont plus à se familiariser
avec la loi et tout donc on a on
diversifie l'eau au niveau du soutien
qu'on peut offrir donc il ya tout le
soutien au niveau justement des
intervenants par la suite on a aussi
bien sur des réseaux qui sont déjà en
place donc on travaille avec les
différents réseaux que ce soit le
directeur de santé services sociaux des
communautés on travaille aussi avec les
partenariats donc très important aussi
le partenariat dans tout ça le lier bien
sûr avec notre bureau politique au
niveau de l'assemblée des premières
nations
donc ce sont les chefs aussi est il faut
être en mesure aussi de bien les
alimenter de les tenir au courant
d'assurer une veille
on a aussi une conne
consultation publique qui est prévu dans
le cadre des consultations avec la
commission laurent donc ça aussi c'est
un stone élément important
on sait que le québec n'y a pas de
cachette on met la main leurs fans un
concert de dire publiquement le système
est brisé donc il faut aussi voir et
faire valoir que de faire notre propre
doit bien ça nous amène vers d'autres
choses et si le québec est en train de
revoir sa loi c'est québec est en train
de revoir ses façons de faire mais il
doit comprendre aussi que les premières
nations sont en train de s'organiser
pour justement assurer un système qui va
leur convenir mais aussi qui m'a de
sécurité qui va assurer le meilleur pour
leurs enfants
donc beaucoup de travaux présentement
jacinthe vous même vous êtes déjà
complètement prise dans l'application de
la loi ces 92 je pense qu'a déjà
beaucoup de monde qui se tourne vers
vous n'est ce pas pour avoir vos
conseils
enfin on est là pour ça oui il ya
beaucoup de pain sur la planche
effectivement et
on est effectivement dans une époque de
sensibilisation de diffusion
d'informations avec la contestation
constitutionnelle de toutes sortes de
questions complexes qui se sont posées
alors nous on est vraiment dans un
travail d' analyse de la situation
juridique qu'on est aussi dans un
travail de support aux premières nations
certaines premières nations se demande
si c'est préférable par exemple d'aller
avec l'article d entendu l'article 35 de
la loi sur la protection de la jeunesse
vertu des accords de coordination de ces
92 oui alors nous on prend fournit des
des pour et des contres dans ces deux
scénarios leur ont alors vraiment un
travail d'analysé on travaille aussi
avec un groupe
alors évidemment je peux tout faire mon
travail à essayer de voir à partir des
interactions entre la loi sur la
protection de la jeunesse et ses 92
kelly position de base pourraient se
trouver dans des accords de coordination
potentiels qui pourraient être soumis et
qui apporterait une certaine clarté en
faveur donc de l'autonomie
gouvernementale des premières nations et
ce serait une loi qui serait comme un
peu loin modèle et qui pourrait donc
être applicable après après un an
si jamais il n'y a pas eu de support du
goût du gouvernement provincial et
canadien a longtemps on travaille là
dessus est évidemment dans les causes
qui sont en ce moment à judiciariser on
travaille aussi à utiliser les outils
les nouveaux arguments que nous
permettent d'utiliser la loi c'est 92
pour rassembler les familles autochtones
l'ours était pas possible sur la loi sur
la protection de la jeunesse
on travaille fort et puis je vous
donnais point que désolé c'est de le
délai peut-être un point que j'aimerais
ajouter aussi ce travail qu'on doit
assurer quand je parlais devait tout à
l'heure au niveau des informations et
aussi de l'application bien on doit
davantage l'eau
mon multiplier cette veille la dans le
sens que on a une loi qui s'applique
depuis le 1er janvier
donc comment on soutient les communautés
à ce qu'ils puissent justement lever le
drapeau s'il ya des choses moi aussi se
rendre compte qu'un principe n'est pas
respecté aucun principe n'est pas
appliquée donc il ya aussi cette genre
ce genre de veille là qu'on doit aussi
assurer aussi années pour que les gens
sachent et que s'il ya des choses à
dénoncer bien ça doit être fait voilà
alors l'émission se termine dans
quelques instants isabelle picard jeudi
j'ai fait un tour de parole à tout le
monde
un dernier tour de parole pour vous
aussi qu'est ce que vous espérez autant
de la loi de cette loi là mais aussi au
temps du gouvernement du québec qui la
conteste actuellement mon dieu j'espère
que le gouvernement va pouvoir s'asseoir
à la table et répondre présent avec les
autochtones je sens pas que ça a été le
corps même richard le disais tout à
l'heure et envoyé une demande une
invitation et ont pas eu de huy de
réponse et c'est dans ce dossier l'homme
et y en a dans plusieurs dossiers donc
il faudrait vraiment que le gouvernement
provincial mettre fin à ce fameux
racisme systémique justement en
s'inscrivant avec les autochtones à
l'intérieur du système
en discutant avec eux je pense que il se
désole seulement comme ça qu'on va
pouvoir combler les failles qui sont
quand même importante entre les peuples
autochtones et le gouvernement du québec
voilà merci à tous d'avoir participé à
cette grande discussion je rappelle que
vous êtes sound à quai dans les bureaux
de la pnq elle donc jacinthe ledoux
avocate auprès de caté avocat un bureau
d'avocats de toronto
marjolaine si oui la directrice générale
la commission de la santé et des
services sociaux des premières nations
du québec et du labrador le c3s pnq elle
et richard gray qui travaille aussi au
c3s paix actuelle en tant que
gestionnaire des services sociaux merci
à vous trois merci beaucoup pour votre
participation et je vous laisse aller
mais c'est sûr que les genres auront
sûrement beaucoup d'autres questions à
poser alors on aura peut-être l'occasion
de se retrouver pour parler encore plus
précisément de cette loi c'est 92
merci merci à vous tous et merci à
isabelle picard ici en studio à montréal
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine on
reprend notre rendez vous habituel du
vendredi pour parler d'une autre d'un
autre thème d'une autre problématique
qui touche les autochtones avec les
merci merci à vous tous d'avoir été là
encore une fois cette semaine à très
bientôt
au revoir
[Musique]